au collège de lévis juste en face de la
ville de québec c'est la journée de la
photo de groupe annuel pour les
étudiants mais c'est aussi une journée
bien spéciale pour une trentaine d'entre
eux pour la première fois de leur vie
ils auront l'occasion de poser des
questions à un réfugié en chair et en os
je suis né à kaboul en afghanistan
j'avais 7 ans on était avec notre
famille on était arrêté d'août plusieurs
fois par les téléphones devenus
orphelins hussein s'enfuit vers le
pakistan avec son frère celle qui
l'accompagnent aujourd'hui est une des
responsables du comité d'accueil des
réfugiés de la paroisse ste hyacinthe
fois qu'il a fait venir à québec tout
comme 400 autres réfugiés depuis trente
six ans et cela sans être de fonds
publics
mais depuis quelques années les délais
d'attentes au doublé on parlait de 3,81
moyenne depuis 2011 je serai 2012 là les
dos et ça prend jusqu'à 7 et 8 ans avant
que la famille arrive avec la crise des
réfugiés syriens la situation est
devenue intenable
malgré de nombreuses offres de
parrainage dans la région la paroisse
sainte il n'arrive pas à faire venir une
seule famille syrienne
même si on les voit le marché à la
télévision presque à tous les soins
j'arrivais pas nous n'arrivions pas à
avoir la référence pour dire je veux je
suis prêtre j'ai l'argent gg lmnp qu'il
faut je veux les parrainer faites les
venir donné l'émoi à québec ils sont
plusieurs à déplorer l'inertie du
gouvernement en matière de réfugiés
malgré la situation d'urgence à
commencer par le maire qui lui a pris
les choses en main tout le monde est à
pied d'oeuvre d'un domaine de saintes et
de l'éducation
non je me
on est ravis qu'ils organisent sur le
terrain on ne peut pas être plus près
qu'on l'ait mais là on est un peu la
patte en l'air on nous disait que
c'était urgent que c'était imminent
elles ont donc une nouvelle voie dans
cet édifice fraîchement rénové le centre
multiethnique de québec auraient la
capacité d'accueillir au bas mot 150
réfugiés à la fois dans ses appartements
et chambres modernes mais son taux
d'occupation n'est que de 13 ou 14 % en
moyenne
au moment où le projet a finalement pris
forme
on a eu des des diminutions vous l'avait
nommé assez drastique qui sont reliés
très certainement à l'ancien
gouvernement et les politiques en place
qui ont fait en sorte qu'on a vu on est
passé d'une année à l'eau de 450 à 350
affaires jusqu'à 2014 en accueil de 135
personnes alors écoutez oui on trouve ça
épouvantable et les syriens on n'en
parle même pas ils sont à peu près
introuvable à québec quand je pense
qu'on a reçu une famille l'année
dernière d'origine kurde d'ailleurs
alors non
aujourd'hui dans cette région qui avec
ses dix députés conservateurs sur douze
a connu une mini vague bleue aux
élections il y a deux semaines
il fallait une certaine audace pour
lancer un plan d'urgence d'accueil de
réfugiés
un plan qui prévoit d'accueillir entre
500 et 800 personnes très rapidement
mais l'initiative du maire n'a pas fait
que des heureux
je précise du de ce niveau l'eau mais si
ces gens là on arrive puis demande
d'avoir une mosquée à voir la viande
casher
qu'est ce que vous allez faire avec la
situation de monsieur drame alors je
vous en prie n'utilisez pas ce genre de
discours de sa me fait vomir
en attendant l'arrivée des syriens ce
sont d'autres migrants qui profitent des
installations de québec
un groupe d'une vingtaine de réfugiés
birmans tout droit sorti d'un camp en
thaïlande vient tout juste d'arriver
mais ils seront loin d'occuper toutes
les chambres vides
bienvenue à québec pour eux c'est
aujourd'hui la dernière étape d'un long
voyage d'une vingtaine d'années passées
essentiellement dans des camps parmi les
plus mal lotis du monde
le centre multiethnique se prépare à
doubler sa capacité advenant l'arrivée
des syriens avec la collaboration de la
croix rouge par le passé lors d'arrivées
de bosna kosovars on est allé jusqu'à 7
800 personnes par année donc pour nous
autres c'est faisable à québec tous
attendent le signal du départ prêts à
des efforts maximums
ils prennent leur mal en patience d'ici
à ce que le nouveau gouvernement soit
formé
encouragés par certains signes qui
laissent croire que le vent est en train
de tourner à sa grande surprise à peine
quatre jours après les élections
le comité saint-yves a reçu un courriel
du ministère de l'immigration des
familles réfugiées au comme par miracle
était identifié 15 familles syriennes
qui sont actuellement au liban alors on
a tous leur nom leur date de naissance
et tout ça et là on peut piger dans
cette banque de quinze familles j'ai
tombé en bas de ma chaise
et pour ceux qui s'étonnent que la
région québec soit si impatient de
recevoir les réfugiés
cela dit la région québec le tournage
est très faible et ces gens là vont
contribuer à faire fonctionner
l'économie
il faut voir ça comme un investissement
pour l'avenir
on est arrivé le 25 septembre 2012 puis
après ça j'ai eu mon premier jour chez
cora déjeuners en europe en 2012 après
deux semaines la première chose pour moi
c'était sécurité sécurité qui la paix la
sécurité ça te donne des chances d'avoir
une belle vue des milliers de syriens
pourront bientôt dire la même chose si
tout va bien
et pour en apprendre davantage sur la
crise des migrants qui secoue l'europe
je vous invite à consulter notre dossier
web
voyez l'adresse à l'écran